[Music]
we now know that the FBI didn't believe
that Michael Flynn lied to agents during
his interview about his conversations
with Russia's ambassador to the United
States but the Special Counsel
prosecuted Trump's former national
security adviser for making false
statements to the FBI anyway that
duplicity was revealed Friday when key
redactions were removed from the house
Intel report on the Russia investigation
to tell us why all this matters and what
it means from New York its former
federal prosecutor Andy McCarthy Andy
this is so wild why these redactions are
being done the justification for
continuing to remove critical
exculpatory information from these
documents tell the Fox viewers what they
need to understand about this tonight
well it was really outrageous the way
this was done Laura was on Friday night
that they dumped out this the unredacted
previously redacted and what we learned
when you compared the two documents once
once we got the new passages shown is
that what they had tried to conceal was
the information that was exculpatory in
nature about Flynn and the information
that actually went to their
decision-making process including how
they investigated Flynn the fact that
they couldn't get their story straight
about what the basis of considering him
to be a criminal suspect were it just
really very depressing for somebody who
is proud of you know having come from
the Justice Department working there for
such a long time I mean some of the
stuff they held back was actually public
information that was out already but
they didn't want to put it in in the
context that that it came up in the
report because it calls into question
the prosecution of Flynn yeah so from
the beginning one could then surmise
that the screws were turned on Flynn
after he had those conversations with
the Russian ambassador I think he
thought he was allowed to have
conversations his incoming National
Security Advisor Sally Yates rushes over
to his office the
acting Attorney General brings a couple
agents including Peter struck and he's
yeah I'll answer question even have a
lawyer present it's my understanding he
just sat down and answered questions
yeah and here's why this is so bad Laura
if you want to have they say they're
pursuing a counterintelligence
investigation you got a guy like Flynn
who's got a big intelligence background
he's a combat veteran of the United
States actually wrote a book in 2016
that labeled Russia as an enemy of the
United States right so if you really
want to advance your intelligence
knowledge and you have a recording of
Flynn's conversation with the Russian
ambassador what you would do is play the
recording for Flynn and ask him what did
this mean what did that mean so you can
enhance your understanding right what
they did instead was ask him questions
about a conversation they are not a
recording of yeah they already have
reason is there for that other than to
try to get him to trip up yeah well
we'll get to Ellis's comments about how
the how the Muller investigators who
have been operating in a moment judge
Ellis I want to play a flashback from
when Jim Comey sat down with Brett Baier
and what he was asked a specific
question about Mike Flynn let's watch
did you tell lawmakers that FBI agents
didn't believe former national security
adviser Michael Flynn was lying
intentionally to investigators no you
didn't I saw that in a media I don't
know what maybe someone misunderstood
something I said I didn't believe that
and didn't say that Wow what about that
Andy well you know I guess to split
hairs I guess if you were inclined to do
that what he said and they quote him in
the report is that the agents didn't
detect any physical signs of somebody
who was trying to conceal anything you
know I mean I really wear it like how
many angels on the head of a pin time to
try to split those hairs right all right
so Devon Nunez is just hot and bothered
about the fact that he can't get
documents or they're redacted for no
seemingly no good reason and so he's
basically threatened Jeff Sessions
Turney general with contempt if this
stuff doesn't start coming
over to the hill sessions today came out
he said look I'm willing to sit down
with him got his attention the White
House apparently threw mark short the
domestic policy advisor said we stand
were supportive of our cabinet members
Joaquin Castro the congressman from
Texas was on CNN this afternoon let's
watch what he said this probably
wouldn't be happening unless the White
House somehow gave its blessing to go
around and somehow punish Jeff Sessions
through the Congress your experience
with Devin Dunas does he ever do
anything that goes against what the
White House wants no I think at this
point well not at this point for a while
now he has basically been somebody who's
doing the White House is bidding I mean
I wanted to scream out objection leading
from from Blitzer that's a that's an
anchor asking a question you think
Trump's a jerk yeah your your reaction
to that's always bashing Devin Nunez
he's the boogeyman he's the bad guy I
mean while they don't go to the
substance of the problem here yeah well
it's remarkable that you know here at
Nunez I think is actually doing the work
of the people in terms of somebody
having a check on what's gone on in
these investigations and it's
appropriate that that be investigated
and it's just remarkable to me right as
we're looking at this report that has
these redactions that are so ridiculous
that even the Justice Department can't
justify them that's why they they put
them out so you have to wonder
everything else that they're withholding
why are they withholding it and yet
they're attacking Nunez you would think
they would be attacking the people who
were you know holding back the documents
the one fair criticism I think they make
is that ultimately the presidents in
charge of the executive branch and he's
got to do to my mind he's got to do a
lot more than than tweet that he's angry
that there's not enough cooperation I
think he needs to like start giving
people orders to cooperate and finally
judge Ellis Eastern District of Virginia
you know him well I know him well
a no-nonsense judge my reagan appointee
he put this he he was pretty pretty
adamant on friday with the special
counsel's office that it seems like they
don't
care about mana fort they want to use
man afford to get Trump your reaction to
that back and forth Andi Napolitano said
people are kind of exaggerating the
importance of what happened on Friday
well they may be exaggerating the
importance in the sense that I you know
I don't think the case against mana Ford
is going to disappear even if you know
the judge were to strike the indictment
I and I don't think he's about to do
that but my main reaction Laura is that
I'm glad that finally the questions that
we've been asking for a year about the
special counsels jurisdiction about the
non-compliance of the Justice Department
with the regulations in choosing him
about the way this investigation has
been conducted from soup to nuts they've
been able to ignore the peanut gallery
but this is a federal judge who's asking
the same hard questions and and they
have to deal with them all right
everybody read Andy's great piece in
National Review about this whole
reduction withholding of documents mess
Andy thanks so much